how are you greetings cristian cásseres
klinsmann cultural and informative in
spanish today october 15th is precisely
the deadline for thousands
of mgm employers and websites that since they
must show proof of
vaccination against the hobbit this rule
only applies to
salary employees  and everyone
starting work at these hotels in
a statement GM sent out a
reminder that all employees
earning for now must still provide
proof or pay $15 for a
weekly screening in Huesca if you
require your entire workforce  be
vaccinated by october 15
however there will be exceptions for
medical reasons
the retiree center is martin
luther king' is organizing a
health clinic today that's right it starts
at 8 in the morning and will last until
4 in the afternoon
you can get an eye exam,
flu vaccine or mammograms, the
clinic will also give
free advice and distribute  going
to yorkshire produce and food and returning this
weekend starting at 10 everyone is
invited to come to sanse park for
the renaissance festival for one
day tickets are $15 for
adults and $8 for children if they
wish to attend  the 3 days then your
ticket will cost you 35 dollars for
adults
and finally we move on to the
weather forecast we will have some breezes
for today reaching a maximum of 73
degrees in the afternoon this weekend
temperatures will go up to 80
degrees we will continue with  Nice weather
for next week
Cristian Cásseres greets you with his brief
informative on swimming innings in Spanish
Good day
[Music]